so we're going to have a tandem chess
match today it's not the most common
type of chess but Rex is pretty
experienced at this basically there's a
two versus two match where one side like
the white pieces will be playing
alternatively so Rex will play one move
then fabiana will play the next one and
then it goes back to Rex stay with the
black pieces now the interesting part is
that the partners cannot actually talk
about chess with each other so the team
is only as strong as its weakest link in
the world
the conversation around baseball
managing is thinking so many steps ahead
and you guys are so many moves ahead
that you've already memorized so many
different strategies it's it's mastering
a crap that's grandmasters a great great
name for it and just something that I
have a great deal respectful we'd like
to recognize very special guest that is
witnessed this evening James Burton a
retiree an army veteran was leading a
chess class but 16 children in
attendance last was interrupted with a
young knife-wielding fell into the room
and they just attention that he intended
to take some lives he distracted the man
told the kids to run to safety and they
all made it out safely the knife wittily
man tried to attack mr. Vernon but his
army skills kicked in and he held him
off and although he suffered some
lacerations he subdued the man and held
him for the authorities mr. Berman you
are truly one of the toughest chest
teachers I've had the mission when
something must be done risk risk injury
do it thank you all very much
you